je vais le dire chaque les jeux normaux
m'arrêter là bas symptômes qui a dit
qu'ils avaient une place qui avait du
monde là bas donc c'est là donc je vais
m'arrêter à première nuit est à la rue à
paris j'avais 14 ans était en 99 je
partis du havre et j'ai pris un train
pour me retrouver à la gare de
saint-lazare en sortant de cette gare
j'étais complètement paumé moi et mes 14
ans et comment sac à dos pas de papiers
d'identité
justin change pas d'argent le ventre
vide sans le sou et j'arrive dans une
grande ville je connais pas ce soir donc
je trouve un endroit où dormir mais
demain matin quand je vais me lever
j'essaie toujours pas ce que je vais
faire
quand je croise les gens dans la revue
j'ai pensé je n'ai pas forcément envie
qu'ils sachent que je dors dehors et je
convie qui me jugent pleuvait des cordes
mais des grosses cornes et donc la
première chose que je me suis dit
j'étais quasiment déjà trempé à marcher
dix minutes un quart d'heure je me suis
dit il faut vite que je trouve un gros
chèque
je viens de voir qu'un parking ici je
vais aller voir si je peux trouver un
endroit pour aller dormir là bas au
moins je serai au sec
et puis bah tant pis si je me fais des
réformes
donc là il ya une grille mais avant il y
avait pas de grille juste avant
j'arrivais civile voyais un renfoncement
il ya quelques voitures je peux être à
l'abri
ce soir je vais venir je vais prendre
des cartons sec je vais venir me poser
dans un coin là bas en espérant que et
pas dans le monde comme quoi un seul
truc qui est dommage c'est que
à cette petite musique donc la journée
il n'avait pas trop forte mais la nuit
ces deux dispositifs anti sdf mettre la
musique très très fort les vivaldi et
mozart vivaldi et quatre saisons les
albums de rock et où je les connais par
coeur à force de nous avoir entendus
toute la nuit à des volumes
incroyable donc tu dormais s'endormir ça
veut dire tu dormes était toujours dans
un état de conscience
donc en fait je dors mal moi après ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est quelle aussi les
gaz d'échappement toute la journée toute
la nuit ça roule
le matin je travaille dans la gueule
toute noire title avait vite fait là
après je vais monter voir dans les
étages c'est pas des toilettes et un
lavabo du coup voir tout cela de la
tronche le matin avant de partir quand
je me réveille de ma première nuit dans
ce parking
j'ai une grosse appréhension je connais
pas le quartier je connais pas les gens
qu'ils fréquentent j'ai faim j'ai eu
froid
j'ai encore un peu mouillé donc je me
dis je vais sortir et je sors je sors
dans le quartier de châtelet les halles
et je commence à tourner un peu dans les
rues voire un peu les places qu'ils
existent va voir quels gens fréquentent
fréquentent ce quartier de châtelet
c'est tellement gros pôle des changes
que tu as vraiment tous et a besoin
tous les sans abri pass 1 jour par
chaque l'élève obligatoires
pas changé d'un iota cette place
toujours les mêmes traces d'usures de
skateboard et foncez les prix moi même
j'ai participé à ça des gothiques des
teufeurs des skateurs un petit peu de
keira il y avait un peu de tout le monde
et tout le monde traîner avec tout le
monde et dans ces personnes là il y
avait des gens à la rue il ya des fois
où je resté toute la journée ici
j'arrive à 8 heures je repartais il
était 22 heures on faisait rien de la
journée certes mais au moins on était
ensemble les groupes c'est ultra
important si tu rentres pas dans un
groupe tu peux avoir de la considération
pour toi même mais le fait que quelqu'un
ne te considère ça c'est vital aussi
quoi les personnes que tu rencontres
elle devient ta famille une famille si
tu regardes bien c'est pas forcément
celle que tu as et celle que tu te fais
celle que tu choisis on appelle ça une
famille de coeur des frères et des
soeurs de coeur aujourd'hui j'en ai dit
mais le sort terre et en plus moi je moi
j'ai j'ai eu ce problème j'ai pas une
famille se déplacer à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance je mets trois ans partis du
havre
à la base j'étais dans un foyer chez une
sortie de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
jetant dans une famille d'accueil dans
laquelle ils m'ont enlevé pour mettre
dans un foyer
soyez là je me plaisait pas du tout donc
je fus gay énormément et donc pour
quitter le havre est un peu toute cette
ambiance j'ai décidé d'aller à paris
dans une grande ville ba aujourd'hui ça
fait plus de quatre ans que je ne suis
plus sans domicile fixe et là ça fait un
an je viens d'avoir un logement jeter
sur les listes d'attentes de logement
social j'ai retrouvé un cdi dans un
magasin
mon immeuble est posé sur ce magasin je
travaille au rayon fruits et légumes
quand j'ai eu cet appartement ça m'a
encore arrivé de dormir dehors et de
laisser cet appartement vide avec le lit
vide qui aurait pu servir à quelqu'un
c'est quand même bizarre comme une
dépendance en fait la rue danton vite
accro quoi et ça me manquait ça me
manquait de dormir à proximité des gens
de me lever d'être directement dans des
foules
et puis mine de rien je me sentais pas
encore en sécurité chez moi
c'est une bonne chose que je m'en sois
sorti mais encore encore du travail pour
améliorer qui je suis je deviens
meilleur de jour en jour mais j'ai
tellement été abîmée que va falloir du
temps j'ai fait j'ai passé 17 ans dans
la rue c'est pas en deux ans trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans et même peut-être
pas en disant que je vais me remettre de
tout ça